just randomly get in a room with
billionaires it's a weird trick of human
psychology in business if somebody does
you a favor you feel bad about it
because now you know you have to repay
the favor yes if you ask somebody in
business for a favor can you connect me
with X Y or Z it makes them feel good
and they very often will do it so asking
people to connect you to other people
it's an easy ask it's one that's easy
for people to accomplish it gives them a
good feeling inside because they helped
you and it also makes them feel that
they at some level have something on you
right they can call back in the favor if
they need to when you meet a billionaire
and you want to make a pitch it's got to
be very specific it has to show what
they get out of the deal people tend to
pitch broad ideas and people who you
know are being pitched don't even know
what to do with that